i saw a tweet
and it said
like a happy birthday wayne tweet and it
says some [ __ ] like
wayne been rapping for 25 years
he put out
x amount of albums 12 albums or
something like that said he gave us
nikki he gave us drake he gave us young
money
and he's still in his thirties
salute my [ __ ] wayne man when you think
about wayne's not even 40 yet
nah man being weighing the same age
same age so when i see some [ __ ] like
that
it's like damn been rapping for 25 been
not rapping for 25
that's crazy been in the industry on the
charts
bling bling every time we come right
here he'd been in with the he been
25 years
gave you nikki gave you drake gave you
tiger
[ __ ] gave jay mills
you know what i'm saying
even if you want to be like yeah but
mills you was out before that he helped
rebrand me so i ain't going to
like not acknowledge that
you know what i'm saying
he did all the dedication to the carters
he did all that [ __ ] he went through his
ups his downs he bounced back went
through it with birdman all that [ __ ]
and still in his 30s hey
come on man he's one of them people no
he is no who do i think wayne could go
against him versus he's in he's in the
room
where it's like him they keep saying
drake too i think drake is in that room
dre cove kanye drake hove kanye beyonce
mary j blige i don't know snooping dmx i
would have said no
i love mary but what but mary's not in
the room
mary's in that room no i think like mary
mariah carey mary ain't in the beginning
i honestly feel like jermaine dupree
puff dr dre pharrell they're in that
room too